visites de groupes pour les élus de
saint pierre et du département entre la
signature du pst le plan de solidarité
territoriale et les compétences du
département tels que les routes ou
encore les collèges le département est
au coeur des villes 28 possibles aux
aménagements qu'on va faire ici parce
que ici vous avez des populations coincé
entre la ville du tampon à la ville de
saint pierre qui ont besoin aussi de se
déplacer dans les meilleures conditions
exemple les travaux de la mairie et de
la médiathèque de la ligne paradis
résultant besoins de la population
le département est vraiment dans son
rôle auprès des communes pour donner la
possibilité d'avoir des outils adaptés à
la proximité aux habitants des quartiers
et faire en sorte que les gens soient
dans un contexte plus favorable à
l'évolution et toute la modernisation
qui exige un peu plus loin sur cette
route départementale en rénovation
chaque arrêt est l'occasion de réfléchir
collectivement à l'avenir de ce
territoire permettent le département de
voir ce qui a été fait et ce qui reste à
faire là où ça pose problème
on a vu tout à l'heure les trottoirs
elle a vu aussi malheureusement aucun
endroit où il ya effectivement des
écoulements d'eaux fluviales importante
et partenariat entre la mairie et le
département va permettre à ces
rapidement de supprimer les inondations
des maisons qui à chaque fois subir
aucun quartier n'est seul monde ainsi à
bois d'olives ce dernier arrêt devant le
nouveau gymnase du collège henri-matisse
illustre cette solidarité de territoire
qui se veut cohérent quand je vois ce
gymnase les équipements annexes comme la
mairie les
le réseau routier cela veut dire que les
communes se sont aussi approprié le pst
et mène des travaux financés en partie
par le département au service de la
population
sinon l'ordre des choses bien des
projets sont encore en cours raison pour
laquelle les différents représentants
politiques se doivent de continuer à
partager pour le bien commun
[Musique]